hello everybody and welcome back to the
custom story abduction all right moving
on I'm in the storage area in case you
forgot
Oh block from the other side after you
bring it on I'm out of oil okay okay all
right
Oh locked again what isn't locked
why is everything locked who locking who
locking ah okay okay gimme yes finally
uh-huh
Oh broke it off its hinges no I broke it
off its hinges I saw it all right barrel
yeah oh so strong yeah oh yeah um that
led me nowhere yeah
um I just go into one room to get a key
for another room yep
of course I wasted my turning like that
I'm leaving that one ocean because II
think I need an escape route or boxes a
door with no hinge oh it's dark but I
need to conserve my oil or else I'm
gonna always be walking around in this
dark
okay.what chairs or more different tears
nothing man a whole lot of nothing
shovels for coal I don't need man oh
pitch blackness yes I like this makes it
creepy ha ha ha no no no Hey
huh ignore me you didn't see a damn
thing goodbye buddy have a nice day I
think I need to go in that room but
whatever is gonna wait out here for you
to go away
okay yeah that was fun did you go
bye-bye
hello hello hello are you there I don't
see you are you gone
you're still there it was pitch black I
didn't see a damn thing but you were
there weren't you high up there you're
there you're there nope nope
Oh after you man I'll just bring it how
much one enough oh just bring it oh yeah
I'm making noise cuz I want oh no I
don't want you to come in oh [ __ ] oh
[ __ ] okay I'll just show down oh oh
what's this oh oh what says you need
some chair in your life I'll back Oh
gimme gimme oh you know get off yup get
away ah no no no no no no no no no no no
no no no no no oh pigs
oh why did I come in here was there some
reason was a reason was there a reason
is there a reason Oh switch switch
switch switch need to quit switch I need
you switch he's right there he's right
there but hi know better I know better I
know better
oh you don't know you don't know you
don't know you don't know you don't know
Oh Pro dodge Oh Oh dodge okay got you
huh Ponzi Largo Oh get away get away
you know wait get away get away get away
okay got you okay okay they're going
this way
Oh coz it was another way yeah I could
go around the other way up close the
door Oh Pro so pro pro pro pro so pro so
pro so problem so pro where was that
thing
where's the thing the thing the thing
the thing you know what thing I'm
talking about
oh go away oh where was it where was it
where to go where'd he go where'd he go
where'd he go where is he where is he
gonna go
where is he where is he oh good golly
was it been back here okay no where was
it where was it I just I'm going out of
my mind hey why is he still aah no no
aah okay all right yeah I'm going out of
my mind
whatever man I'm just gonna let him go
away because pretty sure where I need to
go is on the other side of where he is
stop making noise
levar stop it
he's never gonna go away if you keep
trying to get his attention maybe I
should just leave the area and come back
maybe just go away then oh he's right
there okay yeah go try that let's try
that get me out of here it's gone okay
and then one potato
two potato three potato okay Oh
OPA it's not like the number and they
just stick around forever okay where's
my doodad
where did my doodad go hey where do I do
dad
what the hell really
really you made my doodad disappeared oh
no the doors are did it reset it reset
oh [ __ ]
damn it okay fine what the hell what the
hell kind of lazy stupid crap is that
why is that okay at least okay at least
it didn't make me get the key again so
this is open the monsters gone okay okay
all right I'm okay come here come here I
want a word with you where was where was
it okay it's over there I need to talk
with your supervisor Oh monster nope
gone gimme I'm about to run out of oil
aren't I that wasn't me running out of
oil I just put it away cuz I'm smart
smart so smart smart smart smart smart
errs don't don't push me away
okay
screwdrivers boxes saw blades okay
tinderbox why did I come in here okay
sir oh I got a bucket fantastic I got a
bucket put that fire out what fire Oh in
the fireplace okay I get it I get it
aw so smart ah so not smart
Oh get don't even try it yeah shut the
door on you like this waste oil can you
bash through this door I have no idea I
have no idea okay where did I see some
water
oh of course the fountain duh all right
I'm out of here
oh what's that oh no I know get out of
here get out of here get out I shut the
door on your face No shut the get me
through the damn door so I got shot that
damn Oh No
my life just went out where am I I can't
see a damn thing I can't see anything
can't see anything I can't see anything
I am blind all the red haze of being
almost dead
okay I getting out here oh yeah sorry it
was way dark there but I couldn't see a
thing either man that [ __ ]
just cuz I don't want to make you guys
wait around for him to go away oh the
nerve of him
okay moving on getting some water I'm
gonna put out the fire in the fireplace
everything's all red phenomenal
gimme your water gimme thank you thank
you very much
alright gonna put out the fire in the
fireplace I was wondering why that room
was so small and yet it had two level
transitions right in between it's
because there's more of room after the
fire oh there oh no not more room maybe
just an idle
Oh chest there we go all better now
give me that okay Oh making progress
almost out of here all right gimme gimme
oh man that was a wild goose chase if I
ever had one but finally almost at the
end boink
didn't you dilute just a drip drop of my
blood wait was there anything in my
journal
hidden door in the atrium okay got that
Alexander bromine mercury blood of the
twisted okay
hide nothing I need to concern myself
with boink yep
oh there we go secret door gimme gimme
gimme goo give me sewers oh not another
sewers why I always have to be sewers
yeah it looks good I really wish I
wasn't dying barely conscious because I
would like to see things with my
eyeballs all right I'm gonna pause it
here thank you guys so much for watching
and I will see you in the next part
bye-bye